hey guys what's up I'm Alana welcome to
my channel last week I went to a venue
in Sydney called the nerd cave for the
launch of the new Plantronics line of
headsets the 500 500 e and 500 HD event
itself is basically an evening full of
PC games rocket League on a projector
which is just the best simple games
cards against humanity' and beer and
wine with a bunch of Australian games
media and a number of youtubers but we
also got our own custom spray-painted
headbands for our Rick 500s which is a
thing that you can do with these
headsets before I get into reviewing the
actual technical aspects of the headband
I thought I'd just talk about how cool
that actually is to me to have a
lightweight plastic but fairly flexible
headband you can completely customize
with artwork and it's also totally
interchangeable so you've got your inner
head strap which is padded and then the
outer headband which you can completely
custom paint you can swap out the ear
cups and the inner head strap or the
outer headband basically like playing
headset later but also letting you
neatly customize colors and designs for
those individual components so it
actually all comes in the box basically
disassembled and you put it together
main idea behind every 500 series is
that they're upgradable with modular
components that separate three versions
and it seems they were designed with
eSports in mind at very least it does
feature a bunch of a gear cell branding
via rigged 500 which is the one that I
have is the cheapest at 99.95
it has isolating air cups with memory
foam which I love makes them very very
comfortable as well as the flexible
adjustable and comfortable headband and
headset for longer gaming sessions the
entire heads it actually weighs about
200 grams in total so it's like it's
comfy but that said the sound quality
isn't particularly impressive the base
is pretty consistently epic but the
highs aren't as clear as they probably
could be but for the most part of the
pleather of the isolating ear cups do a
great job sealing in the audio and it's
tons of detail you can clearly hear the
conversations of those you might pass in
a crowd in
thousands creed or whatever it also has
forty millimeter drivers with
low-frequency resonators and a boom
month which flips up when you want to
mute it which I actually love the mic is
super flexible though it's a little
short it always feels like it's a little
too far away from your mouth it is good
quality but I wouldn't be surprised if
you are a little quiet because of the
shortness of it the Auriga 500 HD on the
other hand has 24-bit Dolby 7.1 surround
sound through a cable it's specifically
bundled with and lastly the RIC 500 e
comes with two pairs of ear cups the
second pair the wider vented ear cups
that further reduce a headset discomfort
but will make it easier for you to hear
ambient noise the route 500 HD comes
with those two of course I'm actually
pretty happy with the rig 500 base model
and realistically I could purchase just
extra parts to upgrade it to be at the
same level as the root 500 HD though I
imagined that would be a little bit more
expensive than just buying it outright
so I think this is a really good headset
specifically for people who are looking
to customize it though my personal
favorite thing is how why it is but for
watching the end of this video I'm
actually going to give this one away I
just thought that I would drop this at
the end of the video because I tend to
announce giveaways in the headline but
I'm not gonna do that anymore me giving
you something is like a thank-you for
actually watching my videos without a
prompt for a giveaway so what I'm going
to do is completely customize this for
one of you I'm going to paint it with
whatever you want on it and then send it
to you anywhere in the world so if you
want to win this just leave a comment
below with your Instagram and what you
would like me to paint or draw on it
you're curious about my artwork I have a
link below to a bunch of prints of the
stuff that I draw so I think that I'll
be able to get a good quality thing out
of it so you can get an idea for that
and I will basically pick whichever
thing that I want to draw the most if
there are double ups it will go to the
first person who commented so leave your
Instagram username so I can get in touch
with you if you've won and I can start
working on customizing you a headset and
then I will send you off your rig 500
I'm actually really excited about doing
this it seems like a really fun thing to
do so let's do it let's customize some
headsets I'm Alana thank you guys for
watching I will see you guys next time
Oh Mike